alright well I want to take a deep dive
now time Bloomberg terminal and take a
look at the story that i was watching
all day and that's the Iranian nuclear
deal this is a function on the terminal
called noon go and it basically is
looking at all the tankers that are
right around Iran I'm going to do my
best vanna white imitation over here at
the board so as you can see here there
about 10 tankers all across of the coast
of Iran and as of noon today there were
three that were registered to Iran that
had his storage capacity about 10 excuse
me 60 million barrels and Joe this was
really the conversation Jay when it came
to Iran not what they're going to
produce in a year but what they can
offload in floating storage right now an
estimates range from anywhere they have
20 million perhaps 40 million barrels
that really could be offloaded the
moment that sanctions are the terms of
moving markets yes Iran has a lot of oil
that eventually it will be able to
produce but what's what we see there in
that map could hit the market relatively
yes and the real question is what is in
these tankers is it oil or is a
condensate energy aspects estimates that
ninety percent of the oil being stored
it on see is actually condensate does
not want that that's not that hard of a
commodity well my deep dive for today
into the terminals not nearly as
exciting and dramatic is no fun map but
so we got a lot of bad economic data
this morning we got a really ugly retail
sales report this morning everyone saw
that big disappointment and we also got
on one of my favorite measures the NFIB
small business optimism index this index
they asked small businesses how they see
about the economy and usually there's a
lot of whining about obamacare and stuff
like that but nonetheless what they say
each month is interesting and it was
pretty ugly you see there's a pretty big
decline in recent months big down big
downward surprise and look it's still
elevated still wear it higher than it
was a couple years ago but you got to
watch that sort of steady decline to see
if maybe the economy is starting to
creak again all the dots are kind of
adding up